boom era is seven months old and weighs
just over four kilos the circumference
of his arm is nine centimeters for the
nutrition officer at this refugee health
clinic the signs are clear the child was
really malnourished and dehydrated when
Oh Maura was brought in here what looks
very good he doesn't laugh he doesn't
feel he looks he doesn't look okay at
all Amara is immediately given
life-saving treatment he is one of more
than a hundred thousand children across
northeastern Nigeria admitted to
unicef's feeding program three times a
day he'll be given a peanut paste with
added vitamins a week later Amara is
back a hundred grams heavier a small
improvement but before his loud home
he's put on a course of extra vitamin A
and antibiotics and finally two and a
half weeks after he first came to the
clinic tomorrow is visibly plumper
although he's still classified as
malnourished the feeding program has
worked for Amara but the recent
escalation in the Boko Haram insurgency
has left thousands of other displaced
children acutely malnourished but for
now all that matters for mum is Amara
don't worry dear he's so much better
he's not sick he can play he can do
everything that makes me happy there's
enough water Tina